with dignity and respect
committed to free speech and common
sense and entertaining straight talking
and direct we may have to take each
other and you thought provoking
provocative and controversial hello and
welcome to the pledge now we would
normally start the show with a joke a
light-hearted gag poking fun at
something amusing
that's happened this week but this week
British politics is teetering on the
brink of collapse
Prime Minister narrowly survived being
ousted by her own party while the vote
on her brexit deal was cancelled to
spare the government embarrassing defeat
crisis chaos uncertainty reigned supreme
so frankly there's not much to laugh
about but what we can try to do is at
least provide a bit of clarity and work
out what the hell is going on although
looking at this lot are not sure about
our chances coming up on the program
Greg plays the blame game over brexit a
fwah once a bit of inspiration from our
leaders Majid thinks more can be done to
tackle racism and can I say I like your
sweater even if it does make you look a
bit of jean-claude Juncker and Michele
calls for restraint but remember this
nothing has changed nothing has changed
the Prime Minister perhaps at her
tone-deaf worst Jorgen ill-starred
general election campaign last year
fast forward 18 months and guess what we
find ourselves precisely at the same
place as nothing has changed
Tereza may still doesn't have the maths
to get a current deal passed the House
of Commons far from being flushed out
the conservative plotters are seething
and point to the high number of her own
who wanted a dumper the country is no
closer to a deal than it was two and a
half years ago and Brussels presumably
looks on with a mixture of bewilderment
and sympathy actually one thing has
changed the PM cannot be challenged by
her own at least for 12 months this
remain vote
for her means she won't leave and the
plotters are seen as little more than
the gang that can't shoot straight
mrs. May has taken us one day closer to
leaving the EU but we still have no idea
of precisely how lame duck for Christmas
anyone you a Michelle and I often wear
quite bright colors on this show oh
right
and I noticed that today we both showed
up in black and I wonder why I think
we're mourning at the state of our
democracy well I can't speak a few
Michelle but I certainly am particularly
got your doctor well my favorite tweet
actually this week came from Alistair
Burt who's a government minister who
said after the apocalypse all that will
be left are cockroaches and Tories in
fighting over the state of their
leadership which i think is born it was
Tories fighting over Europe that got us
into this mess
it's Tories fighting over Europe that is
continuing to hold the entire country
hostage to this completely farcical
politics and you know I have to say I
feel very mixed emotions right now
because I have no love for Teresa Maine
in terms of her policy I think that she
she's not a politician that I knew who
I've ever felt supportive of but I can't
help the pity her because she is doing
and Prime Minister it's not a good look
but for somebody to make me feel pity
for her is actually quite quite an
achievement and I think it just says
something about the way that her party
is behaving you know she's doing
something impossible it's impossible
because the bricks that was offered is
not deliverable nobody is happy this is
the most unity I feel breaks the tears
are upset remains were upset everybody
feels betrayed and she's trying to make
sense of this and they're just busy
continuing to stab her in the back and
even having won the vote of
no-confidence they haven't stopped from
one woman in black to the other woman in
black Michelle I just think I feel
really disappointed with what's going on
and I watched Theresa May MPM cues this
week and I was astonished that she still
seems to have a sense of humor I thought
she did a really good performance and I
am so surprised that she is still there
I'm astonished that she hasn't yeah just
turn around no no no no I don't mean in
the confidence
she would yeah I'm talking about a
respective that I'm surprised that she
still as a person wants to put herself
through this because I was expecting her
to have gone to know what enough if you
not think you can do a better job go do
a better job I have found the way that
the the backstabbing the the bullying
the the infighting I think it's
absolutely shocking and disappointing
and we'll move on in the programs talk
about why people don't feel passion and
all the rest of it in the leaders that
we've got today politics in this country
is letting all of us down and I think
there's so many people that should be
ashamed of themselves it's caught it's
called the Conservative Party and it's
been the truth it is but the toys should
have split 20 years ago over Europe over
Europe it's a fund it's these the
fundamental issue of our time and if a
political party is so divided as they
are they should have split there should
be two parties there one is Allah is a
remain a party money's would have been a
brexit party and that they failed to do
that means you what happened this week
is inevitable yes imagine I want to
bring you in but first and I have to
warn the viewers there this does contain
flash photography
this is mrs. Mae speaking outside
Downing Street after she triumphed in
the vote we now need to get on with the
job of delivering brexit for the British
people and building a better future for
this country a brexit that delivers on
the vote that people gave that brings
back control of our money our borders
and our laws that protects jobs security
and the Union that brings the country
back together rather than entrenching
division that must start here in
Westminster with politicians on all
sides coming together and acting in the
national interest majid they talk about
the may BOTS the automaton I mean I saw
you watching indeed all of us rolled our
eyes that's not really what you need to
hear that same script is it well no and
especially the conflation of you use of
the word national interest to basically
mean what she thinks is good for the
rest of us as opposed to what the
country agrees on and the country
doesn't agree that's the point so I
don't know beyond uniting behind her as
a person what is it we're meant to be
uniting
there's no vision there's no leadership
being shown perhaps actually though I've
got to say it did probably suit her that
this confidence motion was called prior
to her deal being rejected element well
who wants to be leader with that specter
still looming of having to pass whatever
deal they agree with you I said they
were the gang that's not shoot straight
is that right well it was a conspiracy
theory around about all this yeah now
I'm not a conspiracy theorist but I
quite like the theory which we've
basically said actually mrs. Mays lot
ensured that was this week that they
actually put in enough letters
themselves to make sure to get that out
the way and that she's got some sort of
deal from Europe and that she doesn't
want it in there she gets this out the
way she comes back with her deal and
they'll be more well if you think that's
it if you think about it she goes to
Brussels and they say what assurance do
we have after your deal passes we're
dealing with the same person afterwards
and if we were on the pledges and on top
of that who would want to be leader and
still have that problem let's get back
in really gonna tee up and open go for
you here what strikes me is this is a
woman who is not going to be allowed to
lead the Conservative Party in the
future but she can lead the country at
this crisis at this constitutional time
that is a strange one decision for the
Tories to take is it not I have to say I
really am curious as to what drives her
personally because she's no longer got
and she's pledged not to run again in
2022 so it's not that she sees this
long-term future as leader she's
confined herself to this horrific period
of unwinnable mayhem and it is curious
what would make someone want to put
themselves through that I just wanted to
show you what somebody who would like to
be the leader at this moment has said
this is Jeremy Corbyn saying that the
Prime Minister has lost her majority in
parliament her government is in chaos
she is unable to deliver a brexit deal
that works for the country and puts jobs
and the economy first it's clear that
she has not been able to negotiate the
necessary changes in Europe she must now
bring her dismal deal back to the House
of Commons next week so Parliament can
take back control yes cause he wants to
be leader of the country not not budget
though he is Pro pressing on a right so
look at some of the chaos within the
Conservative Party you know
pick up on this but this is an a Subaru
and Robert Buckland not changing
relations it's more of the trotting out
of the lines the rhetoric the empty
rhetoric it's not going to win Robert
Robert you have to convince people like
me to change the way that I'm going to
vote and they these lines will change
you let me finish please
you have Jeremy Corbyn time the
compromise not for people taking
artificial positions I'm looking for
Nevada Anna it doesn't exist get on with
this the but we also fighting on several
fronts here now that is pretty much a
civil war to your point it is very
embarrassed it's your point that I'm not
so sure that if labor were in this
position say for example the government
collapsed in Corbin took over that it
would be any different
I don't think Labor's got that many
what's labor gonna do great
what are they gonna do they're gonna
keep quiet which is what they've been
doing
cause the Scots don't vote I win and win
the other lot when when you're the
government governing party is in
disarray in trying to kill each other
you've been looking at one of the arch
plotters haven't you oh yeah yeah Jacob
Riis morg let's look at his verdict it's
after this vote it's a very bad result
for the Prime Minister that if you think
163 conservative MPs are on the payroll
minister's PPS is vice-chairman the
party trade em boys and therefore of the
non payroll of backbenchers the Prime
Minister lost really very heavily and I
think the Prime Minister should resign
she cannot get her deal through her very
bad unsatisfactory withdrawal agreement
which is not supported by the DUP by
many conservatives or by the opposition
and having failed in her main plank of
policy it would be constitutionally
normal for her to retire from the frame
I don't mind admitting I used to quite
like him
but I'm starting to feel very
uncomfortable with him and even
narrative and he's lost me I will be
honest and all he's still 163 people
have to ever but no one has to vote for
treason because it's all secret you can
say you've done it and not do it in the
first place I didn't yeah I am about
regs conspiracy theory though and how
many I would love to know the breakdown
of that faith how many of her own people
did it deliberately to get out the way
how many men voted against women I think
is that he's now saying the basic she
got 63% of the vote that well hang what
about 52% of the vote is okay but she
presented and I think he he is the
Biggest Loser this week yes he is the
biggest loser heater he built an image
of himself yeah all built up we got the
week after week and suddenly well